الله يسلمك
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره اهلا
بكم قوته الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقتل الشاب
الفلسطيني نسيم ابو فوده في الخليل ما
يرفع عدد الشهداء منذ مطلع العام الى 35
وسلطات الاحتلال تواصل اجراءاتها
الانتقاميه وتهدم منزلا قيد الانشاء في
جمال المكبر بالقدس
يصرح ولد وصوله تل ابيب بان على جميع
الاطراف التهدئه ووقف العنف
اتهام ايراني لاسرائيل بالضلوع في الهجوم
على منشاه عسكريه في اصفهان ومسؤول ايراني
يرجح في تصريح للجزيره انطلاقا المسيارات
من داخل البلاد ويتوعد تل ابيب بالرد في
حين تحدثت مصادر امنيه عن قصف شاحنات
ايرانيه على الحدود السوريه العراقيه
عشرات القتل والجرحى معظمهم من رجال
الشرطه في تفجير الانتحاريا داخل مسجد قرب
مقر شرطه المحليه في مدينه تشاور شمال
غربي باكستان وحركه طالبان باكستان تتبنى
في تغريده لها المسؤوليه عن الهجوم في حين
رفعت السلطات مستوى التاهب الامي في
العاصمه اسلام اباد بعد انفجار بشاور
شركه فيلبس للالكترونيات في هولندا تسرح
6000 موظف حول العالم وتستغني عن 13% منهم
لخفض التكاليف بسبب اخصائلها التي بلغت
اكثر من مليار دولار اضافه الى تراجع
مبيعتها الى اللقاء